so I'm gonna talk today about data
scientists the number that we have the
number that we're going to need
educational pathways to become data
scientists and so kind of going through
the talk it's going to be motivation of
the problem talking about boot camp
history I I work for galvanize so I have
a dog in the fight
talk about my perception of how how our
company and this educational pathway
addresses the gap and how individuals
can be successful along this path so Who
am I and why do I feel qualified to talk
to you about this so my name is Joe I
finished my PhD in physics from the
University of Florida in 2010 here's a
picture of me at the Large Hadron
Collider which is what I did my doctoral
work on and I started doing data science
as a title although I would say that the
work that I was doing at the time was
pretty indistinguishable in 2015 I
started working for a defense contractor
at the time was called Sottero defense
solutions that got purchased by a
different defense contractor just before
I left but I actually worked alongside
Travis and Peter on the X data projects
at DARPA so the history of that is that
the government thought it was crazy that
they kept paying defense contractors to
develop software and then buying the
products of those of that development
from them from DARPA and so some
enterprising young fella came in and
said why don't we why don't we force
DARPA programs to make open-source
software and then all of a sudden the X
data project was born so as I mentioned
I currently work as an instructor here
at galvanize particularly in the the
data science program so my my primary
occupation is in fact training people to
become data scientists I also do
research in post-secondary education so
I look at metrics of success and people
from different backgrounds than
traditional students
and in ways that they are successful and
look at analyzing the challenges that
they face that's unique to them I'm
actually also working with Austin Aryan
high schools to try to get some of the
open-source tools we're talking about
today in education all the way down at
those ranks so I I do think a lot about
education and at this point I might
humbly refer to myself as a an expert in
the field of education particularly when
it comes to nerdy things like data
science so to briefly talk about the
motivation of the problem by show of
hands who here is a data scientist or
some other variety of that thing well
roughly a third of the audience go i I
might imagine that those of us who are
not data scientists are vaguely aware of
the field and vaguely aware of what
somebody who might call them as data
science call themselves a data scientist
might do on a day-to-day basis um this
this is a headline article taken from
The Economist from a few years ago now I
think that the picture might be a little
embarrassing for them at this point
because I think one or two of those
companies isn't doing so hot these days
but I do think that the the general
notion of data science and predictive
analytics being come becoming a
indispensably important part of growing
companies is going to become more true
as time progresses and so certainly
there is a the the the the biggest
companies in the world will reap the
greatest rewards of this because they'll
have kind of data that intersects many
different walks of life but I think that
the the thought of predictive analytics
and statistical thinking is actually
going to become pervasive down to very
low levels and the analogy that might be
useful for us all to think about is web
development right I'm I'm a child of the
80s I think that I just missed the
cutoff so that I'm part of the hip
their generation although I'd love to be
a gen Xer if I could but uh I got one
left
talk successful but uh the the the idea
is that in in the early 90s very few
companies had a website right I'd like
if you if you went around you use the
wet Yellow Pages when I was you know
when I was in you know 92 I was using
the Yellow Pages to try to find
companies in town for what's the new
pizza shop right now you know if you
start a company you form an LLC and you
get a web page right like before you
even have a product you have a web page
and so while we're not doing kind of
ground-up web development
I might imagine that we are going to
start using analytic thinking from the
ground up and a lot of companies even
today very small shops are using Google
Adwords and things like that and are
already using the the rewards of
predictive analytics in their daily work
so it's not such a far-flung idea that
even small companies will be using data
science so who are data scientists and
and and how do we get you know how does
one become one so there are no shortage
of Venn diagrams showing us you know who
they are this one's pretty pervasive
it's it's the combination of hacking
skills math and stats and substant
expertise I actually really like this
one a lot more just because it shows us
how we can go a ride it has the same
three but it also has a little bubble
for the characteristic of evil and so we
all have dealt with that that gnarly
outside committee member who just thinks
stuff of evil questions during our
dissertation and I would like to give a
shout-out to my grad school office mate
he did teach me a lot but I don't think
he was evil I think he was just
misunderstood but all silliness aside
right data scientists are people who
draw upon a very diverse set of skills
and I think that for the most part you
don't pick up these skills by accident
and it's something that we're going to
kind of circle back to over the duration
of this talk
revisit this notion of how people get
this skill set and how we pick up this
set of skills but it's just something
that I kind of want to plant in our
psyche right now and we'll circle back
to is we talked about this a little
further ok so then another kind of who
data scientists are map is this is the
the data scientists road map I believe
it starts kind of right here on the
screen this fundamentals and you go
along the way and and each one of these
dots represents a skill set that one
would have to pick up in order to be
qualified to be a data scientist now of
the data scientists in the room who here
has not seen this image I think it's a
pretty you've never seen this before and
our data scientists you out really okay
so I this this was a really common thing
to flash and talks maybe three years ago
I've seen it a lot less because of the
point that I'm making is it's patently
ridiculous but it was it was shown over
and over and over and and I I know a lot
of data scientists I know a lot of very
very talented data scientists and I'm
extraordinarily confident that if I
showed them this diagram none of them
would say that they have every single
one of these white you know what little
bullet points addressed in in this skill
set right so so the expectation of what
the skill sets of a data scientists are
are may be more in line with something
out of fantasy right of what what we
need to do and 3/4 of the things on this
page you wouldn't use in your day-to-day
life right as a data scientist you would
not use all these things a lot of these
things are complementary and like if you
know how to use one you don't need to
know how to use the other so so what's
the results of maybe some of these
ridiculous requirements for the job is
that if we do a quick search on indeed
you will see hundreds of unfilled
positions of data scientists and they
all pay six figures right I cannot think
of you know if we were paying janitors
six figures I don't think that we would
have a lot of unfilled right if we have
reasonable expectations of what the
entryway is of who can
these things and and what the pathways
are then I don't think that we would
have hundreds of unfilled positions cool
so I'm going to shift gears a little bit
and talk about some enterprising young
person's idea on how to address this
problem
so if we look at hacker news way back
yonder there was this post and it was
want to become a web developer are you
based in the Bay Area can you take the
next step where you march off and he
launches into what would become the
basis of the coding bootcamp right and
and they emphasize that they're gonna
take eight weeks and this is the thing
that you're going to do for two months
you're gonna sit in a room and you're
gonna have somebody who knows Ruby on
Rails just kind of whap be on the head
for two months until you now know Ruby
on Rails and this started in 2011 right
so this was this has happened quite a
quite a while ago and this actually was
the basis for the first kind of
immersive program incubator boot camp
whatever you want to call it and so the
the question might be well why why would
somebody make this venture why would
somebody do this and there seems to be a
pretty strong misalignment between the
things that are asked from job
requirements and things that are asked
in in theory now I I don't know how many
of you still work with people very young
in their career or are yourself a young
person in your career but one of the
things that categorically makes people
tear their hair out is it's a junior
developer role that requires two years
of experience and if you do this at your
company stop doing that like if it's a
junior position if you can if you can
demonstrate that you've built something
as an academic project like then you can
do the job right of a two years of
experience is very disheartening for
applicants and and it's it's a it's
pretty silly to out of another show of
hands just as a fun little interactive
thing who here as a part of a job
interview has been asked to program up
depth-first search
show the hands and no I know that
there's more than yeah okay so and and
who here as part of their work has ever
had to program depth-first search really
it's so surprising okay so I've been
asked to program depth-first search on
no less than five job interviews all of
which I had no computer science
fundamental like work that I was doing
on my day to day basis
and so again the connection between what
we teach in theory and what we teach and
what what's needed to do the job there
was misalignment
so again computer science education
teaching C++ they're talking about kind
of these these theoretical things and
really the the folks at uber they wanted
somebody who could build something they
want you know we give you a task with
real goals as far as making something
into this world that did not exist
before can you do it and it's it's it's
a pretty binary question can you do the
thing that we're asking you to do or not
and as a results there's been growth in
the industry right so you know if we
Strack though if we track over time
we've had you know an order of magnitude
growth over four years I you know the we
we should have 2018 data in here we
don't but it's a growing industry
because there is a real need in industry
for people who just have day one can you
produce skills and there is not enough
people to fill them both in web
development and data science although
I'm really only qualified to talk about
one of the two and the number of places
have it exploded right so we have a
whole different variety a lot of them
have different emphasis I think that a
good number of these are particularly
focused on web development but we also
have a lot of folks adding to the data
science community and so how do programs
like this address the gaps and and how
do we and how do we kind of maybe merge
what our preconceived notions of who
data scientists are and how they how
they come to be with this new
reality well I want to use an analogy
from machine learning and we talk about
loss functions in machine learning right
and those of us who aren't data
scientists it's basically the way that
we coerce the algorithm into getting the
right answer we say hey you know you
make some prediction and if you are
right we applaud you and if you're wrong
we bop you on the head right and we put
a lot of emphasis on choosing the right
loss function because if we don't we can
create local minima we can create these
little patches where it seems like we're
doing a good job because if we move a
little bit to the left or we do move a
little bit to the right we do
comparatively worse but we're not really
doing the best possible job that we
could right and that's the whole idea
behind picking the right loss function
well the purpose of a college education
is to get a well-rounded education
there's nothing wrong with that I my
life has benefited greatly from having
great access to great universities so
I'm not the moaning the purpose of
education but categorically if you asked
an 18 year old why are you going to
college the answer would almost
certainly be to get a job right and so
when there's a misalignment between you
as a consumer what you think you're
getting and what the company is
providing there's going to be a tension
there right so I just kind of wanted
like Barnstorm highlight one of the
hoops that I make my graduates jump
through is that I film videos of their
capstone presentations and so we we have
and one of the slides that is in every
single one of their talk because I force
it is that they do a technology stack
slide right where they have a slide
where they talk about what they used to
do their projects and as we kind of
circle through we can see we have Python
we have AWS we have scikit-learn and
they're going to look redundant so I'm
only going to show three but we can see
that we have the things that we've been
talking about all day right these open
source tools that are ubiquitous within
companies and they they all come out
having built a project
that works that uses the technology that
companies want right and that that
absolutely positively is the standard
can you do the thing that you're being
asked to do and that is the standard
that every single one of these people
that come out of this program meet so so
circling back and again thinking about
the the kind of the milquetoast version
of this Venn diagram right we have the
the hacking skills the math and
statistics knowledge and the substantive
expertise and I think also a lot of a
lot of emphasis is afforded to the top
two right we we oftentimes spend a lot
of time thinking about the hacking
skills we oftentimes spend a lot of time
thinking about the math and statistics
knowledge but sometimes we we don't
afford a lot of thought to to that last
bullet right that's substantive
expertise and and I have one more job
posting right that you know again just
looking at LinkedIn we have these
various requirements where it's like hey
we want you to be familiar with this we
want me to be familiar with this and
then we also want you to be familiar
with this right and that the the first
things are kind of you you know I could
copy and paste them from any data
scientist job posting and place them
into another one
they'd exist but they'd also want people
to have experience working with
healthcare data right now I know an
awful lot of talented computer
scientists most most computer scientists
are also very good at math so it would
be reasonable for you to go through to
study hard as a computer science major
and end up with a lot of the
qualifications to be a data scientist
right but I I don't know a lot of
computer scientists that are also
experts in health care or are also
experts in the automotive industry are
also experts in whatever right and as we
have seen a lot of data scientists need
to be communicators who really do
understand the industry right and and we
can be
we can we can say that the first two are
are important because maybe the
personality types we have they're the
funnest and most interesting to us but I
really think that those of us that are
very successful in the field
don't don't sleep on the idea of the
importance of the business aspect and
the the non-technical aspects of our
role and I see more and more with my
graduates that I am surprised at who is
very very successful and who does okay
based on that one you know quality and
I've learned a lot in this role of how
really indispensably important this last
bullet point is so I want to switch
gears a little bit and bring in some
information from some of that other
research that I do so the the the Center
for national that the National Center
for Educational statistics publishes
what they call the it's it's a large
survey of every post-secondary education
institution in the country this includes
four-year universities it includes
two-year universities what we might call
community colleges and it even has other
programs that are not community colleges
but they call them less than two-year
programs and and this survey also
publishes a awful lot of information
about the institutions what
characteristics they have kind of gives
us an ability to do an apples-to-apples
comparison of post-secondary education
institutions and and if I look at the
passage rate just for two-year schools
we can see that we have like a very very
clear bimodal distribution here there's
there's one group of schools that tends
to do really well there's another group
of schools that doesn't do so well so
part of my research I you know I'm doing
some data mining trying to find
characteristics that help us make
predictions about an institution so we
can help getting insight into what that
means right the very best predictive
variable we have in this is whether or
not the institution allows you to bring
in AP credits
right and so if we look at the same
distribution there's some of the schools
as I mentioned that the previous image
was two and less than two and so some of
the schools don't even record that
that's why you're you'll see the
relative shift in the the district the
bumps but we can see for those who
record this information those schools
that accept dual enrollment credit have
a hugely successful rate of passage and
those that don't don't what might we
infer from this well I I have some
insight because I look at other
universities but incoming preparedness
matters right those people coming in
with dual enrollment credits almost
certainly view these institutions as
places that they are going to go they're
gonna finish up quickly they're gonna
save a buck or two from going to big
state you down the road and paying for a
dorm for the first year and then they're
gonna move on in their career right they
have a plan they have a vision and
insight into where they're going and
they know what they would like to do
ultimately and those people who don't
are going to struggle more now I I don't
know how many young folks you all get to
work with but it I don't know a lot of
18 year olds that know about the field
of data science right I don't know a lot
of 18 year olds that that you know
really feel like yeah I'm gonna start
working on AI tomorrow right now there
there are certainly a ton of super
talented smart young people out there
and I'm not saying that those people
should not have a fast-track into the
field but there's also a lot of really
really smart people that come to love
these things later in life so so here at
galvanize what do we teach obviously we
can't teach everything from that last
bullet and as much as I talked about how
important it is a I'm not qualified in
almost any field to talk about those
types of substantive expertise and B I'm
just not interested in teaching that
because I'm not any good at it but we
can work with people on the hacking
skills and the math and stats knowledge
and I'll circle back to this picture
because I you know I want to say that
incur incoming preparedness if it
matters in one domain I can't then shift
gears and say oh it doesn't matter how
ready you are here right I'd have to be
logically consistent and if I'm saying
that incoming preparedness matters
incoming preparedness really matters
right so so when folks are coming into
the program or coming into any program
or a course of study particularly when
there are two let's say complimentary
sets of skills that folks are trying to
pick up it's really really important
that one of the two already kind of
exists right so for most of the students
that I come in they have some type of
technical background I'll either have
somebody who's a statistician already or
a computer scientists already and then
they pick up the other bit right you can
kind of lean on hey if I've already
worked as a software engineer I can
already I can lean on that skillset as
I'm integrating this new kind of circle
of knowledge into my old abilities it's
really really really hard to learn both
at the same time overwhelmingly hard in
most cases and that's all I had for
prepared remarks I and I just kind of
again re-emphasize the the notion that
when we're when we're thinking about
data science pathways I do want us to
think about that that experience and
that life experience as being more and
more important and again just as a
person who's worked with a lot of people
I've had my expectations subverted as
far as who will be successful because
that last bullet point which is almost
always under emphasized in folks in our
community it ends up being really really
important thank you
[Applause]
any questions
so you're kind of painting a picture of
like data science thing like this
magical kind of place and you have to
have a lot of experience and maybe even
the skill set is like evolving and
there's other things but a parallel here
is like a law degree or an MBA you don't
get in to be a top in vehicles without
experience you don't get into law
degrees without a lot of like at least
the good ones a lot of experience riding
and doing a lot more Skills than you
finish it off I mean data science to me
seems like I see a lot of schools trying
to shove data science as a whole
discipline
early they haven't built those skills
and so I kind of interested in your
viewpoint of like is this you know
should you follow the path like a law
type of degree or medical degree where
it's building it it's like the capstone
the career rather than the fundamentals
no I think that there's that's a really
good point and it kind of goes into what
I was saying like there's there's very
few 18 year-olds who think oh I'm gonna
go work on AI right and it's not because
they're not what so so so I don't have a
kid or you know have a know a lot of
folks in high school and maybe that has
shifted since the last time I regularly
interacted with high school students so
I will I'll say maybe that's that that's
fine yeah it's it's it's tough to have
such a diverse set of Education crammed
down people's throat now if somebody's
super interested in it we found that if
you can find the why the how works
itself out right if somebody is that
motivated 18 year old that they
desperately want to work on AI they're
gonna figure out how to traverse a
course of study and make it happen
even though it is extraordinarily
difficult but I I tend to find that
particularly with something that's a new
field you know people in the past that
become lawyers and doctors you know I
want I'm going
to go pre-med or I'm going to go pre-law
because their parents said oh this is a
good career right or they had a lot of
shining examples of like oh you do this
and like you can grind it out you can
check the boxes and if you are you know
if you are a lawyer you will be well
paid it's kind of less true now being a
lawyer is less of a safe bet as far as
paying for your law degree even I think
that there's been a whole rash of
lawyers declaring bankruptcy because law
school is really expensive and things
like that but yeah I do think that I do
think that there is definitely room for
supplementing people who are interested
in getting them a skill sets to to
complement an existing skill set to grow
and and and there is a lot of value in
having some experience working as a
software engineer or as a statistician
before you make that transition you know
I I don't feel like I've addressed your
question because I'm seeing eyes going
up to that direction so do you mind
clarifying if I've kind of completely
missed the mark
so I'll make two points if you ask any
ER nurse if there's a doctor in this
world that can set an IV I'd say that
like it's more of a rarity that a doctor
can set an IV than the the normal case
and maybe what I'm instead advocating on
behalf of is that as as the demands of
data science are going to continue to
grow we need to winnow out junior data
science positions right and and and the
vast majority of the data science job
postings you'll see are I want a PhD in
a quantitative field and five years of
experience right now there's some good
motivation for that right data
scientists often are decision makers
maybe if we're thinking of kind of like
hierarchies within team there are
leaders of small teams and so there's a
lot of good motivation for wanting
somebody who can who doesn't need a lot
of management for initial data science
roles but as the amount of work is going
to increase and it will write we need
people that are motivated have day1
skills and maybe would benefit from a
little guidance right and so I'm not
saying that traditional paths to data
science are wrong right I I benefited
from that it would be pretty
hypocritical for me to say like you
shouldn't be hiring PhDs I'm just saying
that if that's the only way a large
company sees as building their data
science staff the the number of PhDs
that are graduating on a yearly basis
whose goal it is to become a data
scientist is pretty small right as a
physicists I can tell you I did not go
to grad school to become a data
scientist and and I don't know
anybody who goes to physics grad school
to become a data scientist I don't know
anybody that went to stats grad school
to become a data scientist now that may
change because of the fields become more
popular but I I you know now computer
science it's a little bit less of a leap
of faith right so I'm sure that there
are you know computer science PhDs that
are that that that maybe their intention
but that's an awful long track just to
get ready to do a job
right and should we hold ourselves to
lower standards no but should we be
self-honest about like what we're doing
on a day to day basis and and what the
actual standard for starting the job is
I think that's a reasonable debate
there's also someone in the back and a
lot of times and a lot of I've seen is
I'll teach you the math and stats
knowledge and the hacking skills but I
won't teach you how to look someone in I
explain to them a complex topic and a
way to three um so I I can't speak to
every program in the world right I can
only talk about my experience but that
is actually something that we
specifically address we do have review
days we do have communication as an
emphasis in these in their capstone
talks you know we make an emphasis that
you're not just talking to substantive
experts you are talking to people who
may be recruiters maybe from HR maybe
are somebody else on the team right and
so you know if we if we want to show you
know how our models doing which we all
want to show how hard we worked and how
good we did right we show a ROC curve
and we say I got an AOC score and a
precision and recall and like every
single one of my students like you know
first round of talks they have all these
metrics and it's like stop like what a
very intelligent high school student
understand that know you like if you put
a number on that screen you have to
explain it and these are four minute
talks so you can't explain all those
things so you got to choose one and so
yeah we do emphasize that a lot and it
is absolutely an indispensably important
part of the skill set is communicating
with non-technical
yeah for those of us that are old enough
not to be able to get a job in Austin
and that have substances experience and
hacking skills and whatnot is salary
salary really impressive in Austin I was
here a couple of months ago where you
guys had the you know the galvanize
alumni talking about their salaries and
what it was like after they graduated in
salaries just did not seem really
impressive so I wanted to get a sense
from us where are you coming from I'm
sorry where are you coming from
where am i coming you said that you're
not from Austin from here okay so i I've
had people who in three months have
doubled their salary so I you know if
you don't think that a you know $100,000
starting salary is is impressive that's
that's fine that that's a great life
you've wound it out for yourself but
many of my graduates are very happy with
the amount of money they're making we're
not the San Francisco Bay right so I
don't think that I think that there's
only one graduate of the program that's
broken to K from the Austin campus as
their first thing but they also had a
ton of experience in other like
complimentary fields but a lot of the
people that are coming into the program
have been working as high school
teachers or other things and I can say
that they're all doing much better
financially than they were before
now I would also say that pure money is
probably a bad motivation to do a
program like this they're they're
they're easier ways to get rich you have
to do the program because you really
like being right all the time and
arguing with people right I also have a
secondary completely non connected goal
of like I want to make me nerdy uncool
again
because I think it's important that
people that are aspiring to be nerds are
willing to fight a lot and I think
that's important yeah exactly
hi thank you very much for very
interesting presentation can we go back
to the slide with that screenshot from
Hockey News about the very first boot
camp ever offered in history yeah so
what what what cooks interesting here
from is this line no computer science
background required no in my life I
heard maybe 500 maybe more people most
engineers I interviewed a few thousand I
can hardly imagine hiring a person who
knows a programming language but who
doesn't understand from the mountains of
computer science no not necessarily that
person actually has computer science
background that could be math
engineering but I don't know if it's
possible to master programming without
hitting some kind of stem background and
perspective I'm not entirely sure that
the promise of those boot camps makes
sense for people who don't have any
background so my question is the
question is in your experience for data
science boot comes what is the ratio of
people who enter those boot comes with
no stem background nothing knowing and
still after the gradiation being able to
successfully work as scientists versus
people watch we get have stem background
so there's a there's a couple things in
there I would say that the market
generally disagrees with your thought
that people with no stem background
can't become engineers right there's a
lot of very big companies that have
hired graduates from for pure
engineering roles those folks have gone
on to be very successful you know I'm
also gonna be you know I'm willing to be
honest like as with any school not every
person that comes into the program is an
all-star
right we have people that are very good
that come in and MIT that makes my job
easy right if you come in with a PhD in
computer science
like I have a I have to move the needle
pretty small distance in order to land
you somewhere and how do you be
successful and I do have folks like that
that come in yeah
I mean there's no without a doubt those
people are easy to teach right but I've
had people that come in have come in who
were high school teachers are now
working at Facebook right I've had
people who are you know come in with
other backgrounds and like I said double
their salary over the course of three
months and do leave able to build data
science projects now do they would they
need management sure like the folks that
come in in junior levels may need
management I can also say that I know
PhDs that have come in to things and
don't know what a random forest is one
was me right I got hired as a data
scientist I'm on my first job I was
asked okay hey we have this problem
where we have this big spark cluster I
want you to connect to the spark cluster
and we're trying to do this and I want
you to build a random forest I literally
in the in the string of words that were
said to me by my manager I didn't know
what any of them meant right so so
certainly people from stem background
sigh you know I be a little bit airing
because that's where I'm from I think
that they're sharp people they think
they're good at figuring things out and
digging in and learning things but it's
an incomplete picture I don't make up
numbers off the top of my head I'm a
numbers guy so I I don't know off the
top of my head and I'm not going to try
to make one up I feel or my concern is
like we are assuming like a bet if we
are hiring this triangle graduate from
boot camp people since if we hire this
data scientist maybe you will need a
machine learning engineering like almost
onside on him and also a date engineer
or stuff like that what is your concern
about that because like to getting on
production there is a lot of like a big
big gap
some analyses so I I can use one piece
of anecdotal evidence from from my
graduates in a particular company in
town cerebri I write
so cerebri AI was a company that had
been hosted here
they hired I think like five graduates
across like three classes they moved
across town and they also hired people
from more traditional tracks so because
we emphasize hard skills like spark like
Postgres you know so nobody leaves here
without being able to write an SQL query
nobody leaves here without being able to
connect to a spark cluster and do some
simple things right they were able to
build deployable products with a
reasonable amount of ramped up time the
PhDs that they were bringing in because
PhDs are trained to tinker and think
about things deeply and bla bla bla bla
bla they chant they really struggle to
get things working in production because
that's just not what you're trained to
do right and I well I'm willing to toss
out this anecdotal example I I've heard
that's more than norm than like some
exception that that folks from academic
backgrounds really aren't used to
deadlines really aren't used to doing
things on a set timeframe the the phrase
the perfect is the enemy of the good
really doesn't mean anything to them and
so there there are certain realities to
working in the real world that I promise
you I engineer into my version of the
program that most academics don't
encounter over the duration of their
careers
how much would you say like a data
scientist is a person who undertakes a
research project versus somebody who
implements something that you already
understand what you want I think that's
where you draw the line with swing like
is a PhD going to be useful um yeah no I
I I do think so the the talk is not
supposed to only be PhD bashing the only
PhD I'm trying to bash is my own I'm
trying to have a little be a little
self-deprecating but yeah most people
who get a PhD are pretty smart right
they're they're they're pretty hard
working they're you know that they're
not just the foibles that I'm bringing
up I'm just saying that if we're
thinking of you know some gold standard
where a PhD is a person who has no
shortcomings as they come in and don't
have to learn things on the job I I
don't I don't agree that most PhDs also
don't have something to learn on day one
of the job right and so not I'm not just
trying to categorically like be means to
my compatriots who also made the mistake
of going to grad school yeah exactly and
I think that I'm getting the the
shepherd's crook that that's my time
thank you very much for your attention
and some of the great follow-up
questions if you want to chat more but
feel free to find me
[Applause]